cette vidéo elle est pour tous ceux qui
veulent le vélo'v sérieusement leurs
vidéos c'est pas des petites astuces du
petit truc des ti maintenant c'est
vraiment le voilà bien bien bien le vrai
level up quoi et salue les gens derrière
l'écran c'est françois pour la chaîne
explique mme encore je suis ravi de vous
retrouver une nouvelle fois sur cette
chaîne pour parler de vidéo et on se
retrouve aujourd'hui face caméra pour
changer un petit peu parce que j'avais
des choses à vous raconter si vous
suivez un petit peu la chaîne vous savez
ça fait quatre mois que je suis sur un
très très gros projet à savoir un format
hybride entre la websérie le tuto pour
être un truc assez énorme d'ailleurs si
vous l'avez pas vu sa fille cheveux ici
ou là d'ailleurs le dernier épisode
sortira le mardi 22 juin à 18 heures
donc je vous conseille d'activer la
cloche et de vous abonner si ce n'est
pas déjà fait pour voir comment toute
cette histoire va finir et le truc c'est
qu'en bossant sur cette web série et ben
je me suis rendu compte qu'en quatre
mois j'avais appris plus de choses que
les deux ou trois dernières années
j'avais progressé encore plus que dans
un laps de temps assez énorme et tout ça
grâce à des petites habitudes de travail
que j'ai envie de vous expliquer un
petit peu dans cette vidéo pour que vous
puissiez vous aussi profiter un petit
peu de mon expérience et de ce que j'ai
vécu ce qui m'a permis d'apprendre
alors bien entendu c'est pas valable que
pour la fiction assez valable pour
n'importe quel type de vidéo c'est
accessible à tout le monde à condition
d'avoir un petit peu de motivation
d'avoir un petit peu l'envi de vraiment
vraiment progresser parce que comme je
le disais en intro c'est pas des petits
conseils des toutes petites astuces par
ci par là c'est vraiment du travail de
fond c'est vraiment selon moi le
meilleur moyen de progresser réellement
errants de commencer une dernière chose
ces conseils ils s'imbriquent les uns
dans les autres
ils vont ensemble donc rester bien
jusqu'à la fin de la vidéo pour avoir le
propos dans son ensemble et c'est parti
pour le premier conseil ou du moins la
première habitudes de travail c'est de
préparer vos tournages ça vous le savez
déjà mais comment les préparer au mieux
pour que votre tournage se passe le
mieux possible pour pouvoir avoir la
meilleure qualité possible
alors la première chose à faire c'est
d'avoir un script je vous mets en
descriptions et puis je vais afficher je
pense le script d'un des épisodes de la
websérie pour vous montrer un petit peu
ce que ça donne ça fait souvent peur le
script on se dit bah oui moi je suis pas
scénariste où j'ai pas forcément besoin
de scripts et ou alors dites vous que
moi mon script il n'est pas du tout du
tout académique mais il me donne des
repères il me donne vraiment
l'intégralité de ce que je vais
et ça m'évite d'oublier des choses ça me
permet aussi d'anticiper parce que ça
c'est le plus difficile
anticiper son tournage c'est très
compliqué idéalement il faudrait que
avant de partir tourner et bien vous
ayez dans la tête
exactement tous les plans et tout
l'enchaînement de plan qui va se passer
dans votre vidéo que vous puissiez la
visualiser dans votre tête avant même de
la voir tourner et ça c'est la partie la
plus compliquée la meilleure façon de
s'exercer à ça c'est déjà comme je vous
le disais de faire un script vous pouvez
également faire un story board alors pas
besoin de savoir dessiner pour faire un
story board
le meilleur exemple c'est les
storyboards de martin scorsese qui fait
lui-même et qui sont vraiment pas très
très jolie niveau dessin mais c'est pas
le but le but du storyboard c'est de
visualiser les scènes les angles de
prise de vue éventuellement de pouvoir
anticiper les focales qu'on va utiliser
si on va faire du plan large si on va
faire du plan serré bref le storyboard
ça vous permet de savoir à l'avancé ce
que vous allez devoir tourner et ça
c'est très précieux alors moi perso
j'utilise un mix entre le storyboard et
le script c'est à dire que je me mets un
petit peu le type de plan que je vais
vouloir shooter et le script est un
genre de dérouler qui dit ce qui va se
passer dans la seine dans la séquence
que je vais shooter mais même si ça peut
faire peur script du storyboard l'idée
c'est vraiment d'avoir des repères pour
vous ça a pas besoin d'être une oeuvre
d'art c'est vraiment des repères ici
vous faites ça en amont c'est sûr et
certain que la qualité de vidéo va se
retrouver grandement à mur
la deuxième chose à garder en tête pour
des vidéos de qualité c'est de bien se
rentrer dans le crâne et se dire qu'une
bonne vidéo
ça prend du temps et c'est vrai que moi
le premier quand j'ai commencé je
regardais un petit peu tout ce qui se
faisait en filmaker sur youtube et
j'avais l'impression que tout ça allait
très vite puisque les vidéos que je
regardais été relativement courte le
gars me montrer un petit peu comment il
faisait assez rapidement à ces
succinctement et j'avais dans l'idée que
ben ça a l'air relativement vite en une
heure ou deux on pouvait sortir une
super vidéo
or je me rends compte avec le temps
alors peut-être que je suis plus lent
que les autres mais je pense pas que m'a
plu je passe de temps sur mes vidéos
plus elles sont de qualité
ça peut paraître bête mais pourtant
c'est important ce temps là il faut pas
le passé à faire n'importe quoi ou à
être lent et du temps on aura puisque si
vous avez suivi le conseil précédent
vous aurez gagné du temps en prévoyant
un maximum votre tournage
alors concrètement sur quoi on va passer
beaucoup de temps quand on va tourner la
première chose à mon sens sur laquelle
il faut passer du temps c'est la lumière
que ce soit en extérieur où que ce soit
en intérieur
il faut absolument absolument vraiment
que la lumière soit parfaite c'est ça
qui va faire on va dire 80% de la
qualité de votre image alors à
l'intérieur c'est plutôt simple il
suffit de placer ses lumières et de
prendre le temps de faire des essais
aussi devoir tiens si je la décale un
tout petit peu est-ce que c'est pas un
petit peu mieux quels effets je veux
avoir est ce que je mets une top light
est ce que je mets un trois-quarts est
ce que je fais un éclairage en trois
points
moi je vous conseille vraiment de passer
un gros moment à cet éclairage et
surtout à faire des essais à partir
directement sur voila je passe mes trois
lumières ok ça va à peu près bien on y
va essayer des choses même sur le
tournage puisque vous savez ce que vous
allez film est donc ça va aller
relativement vite dans ce cas-là
prévoyez un peu de temps pour les
lumières quand c'est en extérieur c'est
plus compliqué parce qu'on n'a pas le
contrôle sur la lumière moi je vous
recommanderais d'aller faire des essais
un autre jour avant le tournage pour
voir à quel moment de la journée
la lumière sera bonne ou se couche le
soleil ou est ce qu'ils se dirigent bref
quel est le meilleur endroit pour situer
notre scène en fonction de ce qu'on va
avoir et de l'heure à laquelle on va
tourner ensuite bien entendu si à un
moment sur lequel il faut passer du
temps c'est aussi sur les réglages de
votre caméra il faut essayer des choses
de la même manière que pour la lumière
se dire bon ça passera à peu près je
verrai en post prod
sans oublier vraiment que sur le moment
ça marche nickel et éventuellement
pourquoi pas prendre son ordi portable
si on en a un et faire un essai on
tourne une crise de test pour voir on la
met dans leur dit on fait deux trois
tests de correction colorimétrique pour
voir si ça rend bien si ça passe bien et
bien entendu enfin la dernière chose sur
laquelle il faut prendre du temps ses
leçons
où est ce qu'on va placer au micro quel
type de micro on va utiliser
quels types de prises de sons on va
faire ça aussi bien prendre le temps
monitorer vérifier que le son ne sature
pas que tout va bien que tout est réglé
qui a pas de souffle bref tout ça ça
prend du temps aussi et au final après
on n'a plus qu'à appuyer sur le bouton
enregistrer et ben normalement ça
devrait bien se passer et ça doit être
de qualité enfin le dernier conseil est
celui qui est le plus précieux selon moi
c'est que je me suis rendu compte d'une
chose au fil du temps quand on écrit
lance on a tendance à être un petit peu
un homme orchestre de la vidéo c'est à
dire qu'on va gérer le cadrage on va
gérer
réglage on va régler la mise au point on
va régler la lumière on va régler le son
on va régler tout un tas de choses on
règle le scénario va régler peut-être
même l'acting des fois on va se mettre
devant la caméra et au final je me suis
rendu compte que ça ça nous créé une
espèce de plafond qui nous empêche
d'aller plus loin et de faire des vidéos
de meilleure qualité
la solution à ça c'est de ne pas bosser
seul c'est de savoir s'entourer pour ma
part pour la web série
j'ai totalement lâché prise là dessus et
j'ai fait confiance à des gens que je
connais bien et dont je connais le
talent surtout notamment pour le son
notamment pour la lumière et j'ai
délégué en fait c'est parti là qui me
permettait à moi de me concentrer sur le
plus important à savoir le message que
je voulais délivrer dans la vidéo et le
rendu final au final j'ai eu le rôle un
peu de reals dans la conception de sites
web série et c'est quelque chose que
j'ai envie de recommencer à faire pas
forcément sur ce type de projet là mais
sur d'autres types de projets déléguer
certaines parties puisque quand on est
par exemple affectées juste à la lumière
ou affectées juste au son eh ben on peut
se concentrer pleinement dessus pour
avoir quelque chose de super qualité
alors vous allez me dire oui mais moi je
ne connais personne là c'est l'occasion
de venir faire un tour sur le discorde
de cette chaîne où il ya plein de gens
qui vont sûrement beaucoup vous aider et
puis avec qui vous pourrez peut-être
éventuellement créer des équipes créer
des petites team et pourquoi pas lever
leur encore plus le niveau de vos vidéos
parce que c'est une impossibilité de
tout bien faire dans un laps de temps
réduit ou du moins on pourra pas
forcément aller aussi loin qu'on
aimerait pour la qualité de nos vidéos
et je vous encourage d'ailleurs si vous
les avez pas déjà vu aller voir les
épisodes de ces poètes série qui
s'affiche juste ici en attendant les
amis moi je vous dis rester curieux et
je vous dis aussi à mardi 22 juin 18h
pour l'épisode final de la websérie tôt